i want to start with uh how much i loved
season the five episodes i've seen of
this season it's amazing
it's it's so good um but i'm i have a
million questions so i'm so curious how
did you end up with i believe it's nine
episodes um how did you end up with nine
did you ever consider eight did you ever
consider like 12 how did the nine come
about it it wasn't it was it was you
know eight is sort of that was season
one so that's the number we always start
at and that was this season i think it
was
we were
at least halfway but i think probably
over halfway through the season
when we sat we were trying to squeeze
the story in and we sat down with our
writers and we said i don't i don't
think this is feasible in eight episodes
and so we went to netflix and said hey
are you okay if we do one more episode
and uh luckily they were very supportive
of that but that's how we ended up with
that extra episode but it was not
originally planned that way it wasn't
outlined that way it was always going to
be eight and then it just ended up being
too much story but it's not even like
nine it's it's almost double the length
of it's like 800 pages it's just it's
just a really really long
season which is why it took so long to
to get out and it took us a while to
realize that but in seven episodes seven
and nine are very very long episodes oh
yeah i mean those are full-blown movies
yeah yeah for sure i was gonna say
because the most of the episodes are
like an hour and 15 minutes each are you
saying episodes seven and nine or like
an hour and a half or are they longer uh
um
longer
oh wow
okay
this explains a lot so i have to ask you
you guys are in the end game of stranger
things and i'm curious when you were
writing season four how much have you
guys actually figured out where it's all
going and knowing when you were writing
season four you're building towards that
i'm just sort of curious you know well i
mean you know we had this moment when we
were working on season one where netflix
i i loved actually i'm really glad they
made us do this they go just can you
please just sit down and write out all
the mythology because we would always be
trying to explaining the upside down how
it works to them because a lot in season
one it's unknown right it's all
mysterious but they were like we would
just like to know the logic behind the
mythology and so we sat down with our
writers and we generated it we still
have it it's like a 25-page bible all
about the upside down and you know like
season one we didn't want to reveal too
much but you know we we knew five was
going to be the last season and
we're going you know we got to start we
got to start showing some of our cards
season three was more like we're just
kind of playing in the sandbox right
that's what it felt like to me it's like
oh we got all our toys let's play
says season four it's like okay let's we
we got we got to start telling people we
got to start
revealing there's still more to reveal
but i think steve it's this season for
sure is gonna be the most uh revelatory
um season i mean that we hand out
there's still there's still some
unknowns there's a couple more big
surprises i think but we really wanted
to go okay we're in in-game territory
now so let's yeah let's start showing
our showing our
our hand a little bit and so that was
that was fun but i think as we were
writing we realized oh this is actually
to do this properly and to have these
moments land properly we just need time
and so that's one reason the episodes
lengths are longer and that's one reason
it's it's nine episodes but it was nice
because stephen we got uh
we had
were able for the first time ever to
write all nine we write it
we had all scripts before we started
shooting so we could look at the whole
thing as a whole and we outlined all of
five so it really is four and five or
like of a piece
and this was due to the six month hiatus
that we had uh due to do the do the
pandemics so we don't typically have as
much time usually feels like the train
is going down the tracks and ross and i
are just and our riders are just
throwing down track as we're going once
we're halfway through the season and for
the first time ever we were able to look
at it globally not just season four but
season five as well and they really are
of a piece and there's even stuff this
season where they they they talk they we
just start we're able to actually really
hint at some big events that are going
to happen in season five so and that's a
result of of of the pandemic and just us
being able to sit down with our writers
and really hammer out uh what five is
going to be i'm already out of time i
can't eff and believe it if you guys
ever have more time to talk to me please
let me know
please
we'll figure that out soon i would i
would really appreciate it i just want
to ask about filmmaking and the behind
the scenes of the making of the show oh
yeah
thank you you guys have a great day